everything's got to be gay
so i learned
from metro magazine
this article is a little old but it's
making the rounds again and i had to
bring it up i couldn't miss it metro
magazine
informed me of of something that was
pretty
pretty surprising
straight men in bromances kiss
cuddle
and stand around naked together
didn't know that
a bromance has been defined as an
emotionally intense bond between
straight men in the conclusion of this
study it's very very scientific uh the
authors wrote they spoke about their
desire to cuddle and hug
with their bromantic friends
some agree that this was the case when
asked whereas others offered it
unsolicited as as part of their
definition of bromance in all 29 of the
30 men who took part in the study said
they had cuddled with their bromantic
partner this latest work backs a 2012
study that found 89 percent of 145
surveyed undergraduate heterosexual men
had kissed
he kissed their their bros their bro the
bros straight men most straight men the
vast majority of straight men
kiss and cuddle with their friends and
stand around naked right
now look i'm no scientist
okay i don't have an advanced degree in
statistics or sociology or
whatever i don't think straight men do
this
maybe look this is a british paper and
the brits have always been a little bit
light in the loafers that way so maybe
that's possible i just don't think it's
the case
i think
actually ontology tells us that's not
the case i think the nature of being a
straight man tells you that's not the
case because by definition
straight men would not uh hang around
and kiss and cuddle with their friends
this is something i wrote about in my
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds which i became a
number one national bestseller last year
thanks to you and it's coming out in
paperback again and i really want to
jump up the charts so that i can stick
in the eye of the new york times anyway
that's a digression i talked about how
the left gains power by redefining words
well you see it here
straight men
used to be men the definition of a
straight man was men who don't cuddle
and kiss their male friends
and now the left is redefining straight
man to man who kisses and cuddles with
his male friends
so now there are no straight men this is
this is erasure
this is this is the way they take
control
of society on the left they just
redefine everything and they have to
don't think this is some diversion i
think this is a trap that the
the right actually fell into this with
political correctness they said oh who
cares political correctness isn't a big
deal it's kind of a silly distraction
from more important things like cutting
taxes and getting new free trade deals
oh forget that they're redefining women
and redefining men and redefining our
whole country and redefining the
founding is evil and you know forget
about that for a second let's just focus
on cutting taxes and manufacturing more
stuff in china and that'll help gdp and
that's all that matters no this is this
is the issue frankly the war in ukraine
is a distraction
and and kamala harris knows it and the
left knows it
we should learn it too i'm glad you
liked that clip now i need you to
subscribe ring that bell
hopefully get the notifications if
you're not getting notifications head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you